they're young and wanted employers
across Germany are on the lookout for
new recruits at this job fair Germany's
army the Bundeswehr has set up shop next
to big corporate names with some twenty
six thousand jobs to fill per year and a
continuing image problem its recruiters
face stiff competition to snap up high
school graduates a welcome opportunity
for many who wouldn't have previously
had a chance I have an interview to be a
soldier this interests me because that's
what my uncle does and he inspired me
because I visited him one day at work to
see what it's like a friend of mine had
the idea if you want to study medicine
you have to have a pretty good great
average but you can also become a doctor
through military service and even though
I prefer going the normal route my
grades aren't good enough the Bundys
fair offers a huge variety of
professions and study opportunities most
people don't know this I think it's
simply up to us to actively let people
know the choices we offer and it's my
personal conviction that if you show
them everything we have you can find the
right option for anyone as all
recruiters face the same struggle of
finding suitable trainees the Bundeswehr
hopes to fill in potential gaps by
offering additional training and
character forming to less qualified
candidates the challenge for us is
similar to that on the open market
especially in the mint subjects
mathematics information technology
Natural Sciences and technology we're
looking for IT specialists health
professionals and firefighters anyone
who wants to stay in the army for more
than 11 months has to be willing to
spend time abroad many young people only
have a vague idea of what this entails I
don't know if I find this morally
correct especially if I'm supporting war
but on the other hand I'd be working as
a health professional
so I would be helping people well I
wanted to go abroad anyhow after I
finished my university qualification
exams I wanted to spend the semester
abroad so I don't really have a problem
with that I'm more worried about whether
this will affect me psychologically the
Bundeswehr is investing heavily in
attracting talent it just spent some
eight million euros on its latest image
campaign the YouTube series 12 recruits
got millions of clicks but it has yet to
prove that it will help fill the gaps in
the ranks of Bundeswehr recruits